joining us now is retired General H.R
McMaster CBS News foreign policy and
National Security contributor he is a
former White House National Security
advisor General thank you for joining us
from California I know it's bright and
early for you but we know this is
important can you help us understand
exactly what happened intelligence
officials say that this post is a threat
to National Security in this country do
you feel the same what could they be
looking for up there
it is Gail but this is this is part of a
sustained campaign of Espionage against
the United States so I'm hoping this is
kind of a wake-up call for all of us
it's really time for us to recognize
that the Chinese Communist party is
engaged in this sustained campaign
against the United States and and uh and
maybe we should take other actions that
are similar to shooting down a balloon
which is maybe not underwriting our own
demise with Investments uh in in uh in
in China and and companies that are
associated with their you know with
their military complex uh and and then
also you know uh I think it's really
important for us to to call out the wide
range of behaviors of the Chinese
Communist party including including what
they're doing to their own citizens with
a sustained you know campaign of of of
uh of really genocide against the the
people in xinjiang uh as well as their
aggression overseas
already as you hear it's turned into a
partisan issue many Republicans are say
that the Biden Administration
overreacted here do you feel the same
no I mean I think I mean come on let's
let's blame the Chinese Communist party
then stop putting figures at each other
right we're on the same side so I'm
hoping you know I'm hoping that we can
all come together and this is really one
of the few areas Gail right I mean
everything is so partisan these days
right everything is so political I mean
this is one of the areas where there's a
really high degree consensus right I
mean I mean I I think that when you look
at the behavior of the party the Chinese
Communist party that there's a great
deal of consensus and that we ought to
we ought to you know maybe point fingers
at the Chinese Communist party instead
of at each other
you know SNL made a joke over the
weekend sort of saying way to go USA you
shot down a balloon can you just give
the American people just a couple of
sentences about why this matters and why
we should be concerned
well you it really matters because this
is part of a broad campaign to extract
as much data and information as the
Chinese Communist Party can to gain an
advantage over us and this is an
advantage militarily you know as this
balloon loitered over sensitive sites uh
critical to our strategic turn
capabilities but but also you know it's
it's to get data that gives the Chinese
Communist Party a differential Advantage
economically over us as well and so I'll
tell you yeah what we've been doing for
so long is we've been actually enabling
our own demise with investments in
Chinese companies that are connected to
their their defense establishments well
we have we have allowed them uh to to
extract data from us that is sensitive
whether it's commercially you know from
from Communications infrastructure or
from you know Tick Tock where they're
whether you're gathering information
from your your team age children I mean
I I just think that this is this is I
hopefully a metaphor like remember
Sputnik you know late 1950s and and that
woke us up to the competition with the
Soviet Union I think this this might be
like a less spectacular it's a balloon
you know but but hopefully that's the
moment it'll be a moment where we can
really recognize at a very consequential
competition
thank you General this is so much more
than a balloon we thank you for your
time this morning thanks